after a few hours with breakpoints
immersive mode I have to say there
definitely some big improvements but
also noticeable limitations let's talk
about what works and doesn't work and
what settings you can change to get the
game closer to the Ghost Recon you
probably want immersive is really more
of a series of settings than a game
overhaul if you're looking for huge
structural changes to break point there
is some good progress here like getting
rid of tiered loot and eliminating other
random players from the social spaces
but at the same time immersive further
highlights problems that have been there
from the start
particularly with bad enemy behavior
even when you're doing your best to play
realistically enemies often just won't
play along and there isn't a sweet spot
at any difficulty setting at the default
end of immersive mode you'll still be
mowing through bases like a one-man army
and at the hardest settings you'll die
horribly particularly in sections where
the game inexplicably surrounds you with
enemies right after a cutscene
you'll also still see enemy groups not
quite know how to handle you when you're
inside of buildings or simply not
respond when their buddies get shot
right next to them
maybe immersive mode just isn't the
right word for this the game's
interrogation mechanic for example
really breaks your immersion by letting
you shoot a bad guy in multiple times
before picking them back up and talking
to them like nothing happened this is
more of a robust hard mode for break
point all that being said if you use the
new mechanics in the open world
especially where you can be stealthy it
can really be enjoyable
everything you need to get the most out
of immersive mode is in the custom
settings the first thing to do is switch
to using a single primary weapon it's
honestly one of my favorite toggles
because not only does it look more
realistic but it forces you to choose a
role and that counts if you're playing
alone or with friends it makes you for
example decide of your a stealthy sniper
or a hard-charging assaulter if you
don't have a long-range gun suddenly
enemy snipers become way more dangerous
or if you just took a sniper rifle all
you're gonna have for close combat is a
pistol one quick note when you turn on
immersive mode to make sure you have the
gun you want equipped because it appears
to get rid of your other weapons that
aren't blueprints while the mode is
active the next thing you're gonna want
to do is go to the interface menu and
turn off anything that would pull you
out of the world like damage indicators
and crosshairs break points out is
strongest when you're navigating just
using your eyes and ears some indicators
are essential like objective markers but
they turn on and off on the fly
on that note make iron sights the
default none of that over-the-shoulder
aiming shenanigans next crank up the
difficulty despite its name immersive
Mo's default settings still leave you
way too powerful
multiple bad guys can get the drop on
you fire first and you'll still have
time to react heal and win turn enemy
difficulty to advanced and tactical
difficulty to elite the two settings
sounds similar but enemy difficulty
impacts enemy behavior and tactical
difficulty changes the way your
character experiences the world such as
reducing the number of bandages you can
carry increasing your chance of injury
draining your stamina more quickly
turning off health regeneration and
causing you to throw away any left over
ammo that you still have in your
magazine when you reload turning up the
difficulty definitely takes breakpoint
much closer to the survival game
originally pitched as mentioned above
don't use extreme setting for enemies
because the game has missions that
purposely surround you and it just
doesn't work now that you're playing a
much harder game there's a few things to
understand they've waxed suddenly have a
lot more meaning for example they are
now one of the only places that you can
swap weapons and only two blueprints
that you own
which makes chasing blueprints that much
more important if you run out of ammo
and aren't near one you'll have to
scavenge weapons off dead enemy soldiers
which is new and actually pretty cool
there's a very handy comparison menu
that pops up when you're thinking about
making the switch you may also want to
prepare for battles in a way that you
haven't had to before using crafting
menus make sure to farm resources and
keep your canteen topped off with fresh
water because your stamina will thank
you if there's one thing immersive mode
does do really well it's that it gets
you to slow down and exist in the world
not constantly having to chase looting
upgrades makes everything just a lot
more enjoyable you'll get the most out
of the new harder settings if you still
limit yourself a bit and do things like
wander the open world hit side missions
do investigations but stay away from
anything that channels you into places
where the enemy might not agree to be
immersive with you this whole operation
goes to [ __ ] if we're seen together
let us know in the comments below if
you've tried the new setting and how
they make or don't make breakpoint into
the game that you want for more coverage
of shooters including doom and Call of
Duty war zone head over to GameSpot
thanks for watching
all good here I think